we have these little duncan holes yes
can I just can I calmly like say
something calmly I just set it up go
ahead okay Gary walked out in the hall
he said to Ronnie oh wow how did these
Duncan halls get here who do I owe this
to and Ronnie started yelling at Gary I
said Ronnie who put these articles how
the [ __ ] do I know
so JC's supposed oh he's right here when
we walked in Jason said isn't it your
job to know so that we don't eat poison
food and then Ronnie went from zero to
60 sister my [ __ ] job who the [ __ ]
are you
it's a quarter after 8:00 okay yeah
they're all stuffing their faces with
these doughnuts already obviously
there's nobody driving after 8:00
they're asking me who brought the
doughnuts I was just pretty sure that
they were here at 5:30 you know yes I do
you know who put them yeah who Steve
Griffin but he just found that out we
just found out that we asked to be
launched investigation it was yelling at
one of our other writers here I'm so
angry people just want to know that you
know they were afraid of being poisoned
and that's madness listen they're not
being poisoned how do you know because I
ate one at six o'clock and I'm not I
don't did you die then we wouldn't know
who I say this you're a head of security
right why don't you know when food comes
in here during the show we never [ __ ]
accept it unless we know who it is
otherwise it goes in the can but why do
you blows when Gary is publicize it
always bring stuff in case warning when
they come to warn Jason put it out on
the ground he got very upset when Jason
asked Jason oh shouldn't you know that
he was asking he was a professional were
you being confrontational not at all
first of all I would like to thank
whoever brought them in that was number
one so I signed the way the guy's name
is Steve Griffith yeah Griffin whatever
Steve as far as I'm concerned by the way
should you be eating donut holes with
your side that's a whole second
conversation all right but what was this
conversation was hey I'd like to thank
the person and B I was surprised that
Ronnie had no idea how a bunch of food
ended up on our ledge could I know
anytime someone sends food over the
first person you contact is Ronnie right
and you say Ronnie better when they send
it over yes so that was just
asking you but but it is yeah just a
little and I said to you I go when you
started yelling at me ago we're not on
the air I'm not doing a bit I just want
to know who brought the doughnuts no the
way you asked Jason it's always a bit
there seems to be a hole in the security
so if you get the food here before you
show up any there's no home oh maybe
maybe because there's a security person
here before I get here right I don't
want to spend the whole morning on this
but I see there's a lot of tension out
there everybody calm the [ __ ] down
no they just want to make the [ __ ]
evidently you yelled at several [ __ ]
goddamn Jason oh but they say you yelled
at other staffers about the doughnut
holes yeah because they play in games
now after Jay after the Jason think
they're all walking over and they're
gone who brought the doughnuts who
brought the doughnuts who brought them
what happened you know who brought the
doughnuts you have to know who brings
food in what do you want Chris Wilding
quite God you don't like Chris no he
loves a [ __ ] stir [ __ ] you stir are
you stirring him up I came back from the
bathroom I didn't know anything that had
gone on he starts yelling at me are
these your doughnuts I'm trying to being
a detective it was bedlam it was that
bad yeah my god it was and it's just
yelling and screaming mr. Duncan got so
fired yeah he's doing comedy thorough
investigation right don't carry on with
him leave me alone right yeah leave
everyone a young man yeah you're an
[ __ ]
doing the Ronnie show for nobody all
right everyone go out and work now I'm
like the Columbo of doughnuts